>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> Pamela Jackson: Good afternoon.
I'm Pam Jackson.
I'm Director for the
Center for the Book here
at the Library of Congress.
I'd like to welcome you to this
afternoon's Books and Beyond talk.
And thank you so much
for being with us.
We at the Center for the
Book, are part of the national
and international outreach unit
of the Library of Congress,
and it's our mission here at the
library as the nation's first,
cultural institution, to provide a
rich, enduring source of knowledge,
one that can be relied
upon for endeavoring.
Endeavoring intellectually
and creatively.
And that's definitely
what our author has done
with his project today.
So, we're excited to talk
about that project shortly.
At the Center for the Book, we
promote reading and literacy, books,
and libraries, poetry, and
literature, and we do so to promote
and sustain informed,
and engaged societies,
knowing that they're the
best defenders of democracy.
And we hold that as our mission,
and have talks like these
for the purpose of engaging one
another and sharing ideas and points
of views that may be ones that
we don't always have access to.
So, we like to have the
opportunity for unique
and interesting discussions
and access
to diverse knowledge and research.
And we have that with
today's author as well.
Our mission at the Center for the
Book is carried out nationwide.
We have a Center for the Book
in every state, including the --
and, the District of Columbia
and the Virgin Islands.
And we also administer the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards Program
which allows us to have a
national and international network
of partners and organizations around
the world, who are promoting reading
and literacy in very
innovative and interesting ways,
which helps us fulfill
on what we're here to do
at the Library of Congress.
Just quick housekeeping
before we get started.
If you'd take a moment to
make sure your devices are
on silent or vibrate.
And that is in part so that it isn't
distraction for our speaker today,
but also, we are recording
today's event, so the webcast is --
will be available online, and you
can visit our webcasts at Read.gov.
Please also know that
if during the Q
and A portion you are asking
questions, you are recorded
and part of our recording.
So, please know that.
And then finally, one item
to mention as we begin,
the author will make
a presentation today.
As I mentioned, there'll
be an opportunity
for question and answer after that.
And then his book is available for
signing out in the lobby at the end
of our hour talk this afternoon.
So, the chief criteria for the Books
and Beyond Series is that the books
that we share about here, are
either about the Library of Congress
or published by the Library of
Congress, or researched here
at the Library of Congress.
And using our collections,
most of them maps in the book
that we'll learn about today, are
from the library's collections.
And today's author has published the
book in partnership with the Library
of Congress publishing office.
So, we're very excited
about the project.
And here is Stephen Hornsby.
He's the Director of the
Canadian-American Center,
and a professor of
geography in Canadian studies
at the University of Maine.
He's the author and
coeditor of several books,
including the prize winning
historical "Atlas of Maine."
So, his new book, "Picturing
America," and I have it,
"The Golden Age of Pictorial Maps"
which is lavishly illustrated
and available as I
mentioned for sale out front.
And the note I saw on
it, that there were more
than 150 pictorial
jewels in this book.
So, we're very excited to see some
of them in today's presentation.
Please welcome, Stephen Hornsby.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Hornsby:
Well, thank you Pam,
for that very kind introduction,
and thank you for all --
to all of you for coming today,
giving up your lunch break
to hear something about
pictorial maps,
a passion of mine as you will see.
Before I get started, I
really do want to recognize
and reiterate what Pam had said
about the central importance
of the Library of Congress.
This project and the resulting
book, simply could not have happened
without the Library of Congress.
It began with a chance
and fortuitous meeting
with Ralph Ehrenberg, Chief
of Geography and Map Division.
I was just starting the project, met
Ralph, and right from the word "Go,"
he was supportive and put me in
touch with the publishing office,
with Peggy Wagner [phonetic] -
delighted to see her here today -
who was -- I'm sure, those
of you who know Peggy,
will know that she's extremely
enthusiastic and she really ran
with this project and gave me all
the support that I could wish for.
And Susan Rayburn [phonetic],
also of the publishing
office was a delight to work
with during the copy
editing of the manuscript,
and helping in other ways as well.
Pam mentioned that this is a
co-publication with the University
of Chicago Press, and I want to
recognize also Mary Lauer [phonetic]
who was the editor I worked with and
it was a very pleasant experience.
In fact, for an author, this
project went remarkably smoothly
and quickly.
So, hence the big grin on my face.
It's been a joy to put together.
Well, like many things in life, the
origins of this project and book,
really go back to my childhood as
so many things do in one's life.
And when I was very young, I
spent about a year with my family
in the Island of Ceylon,
now Sri Lanka,
and my mother who was a teacher,
had this map by the English
graphic artist MacDonald Gill
and she I think, used
it in classrooms.
Hence, its rather battered
appearance.
And the map kicked around our
house for many years and it's now
in my collection of pictorial maps.
And I think it was this map
that really sparked my interest.
And I should say that many pictorial
maps were created for children
in an educational role, as
we shall see in a minute.
And this map with the
elephants, the galleons, the sun,
the jungle, sparked my imagination.
But we grow up, of course,
and I went off to school
and was interested in geography.
And went through the
English school system,
and then a university in Scotland.
And it was quite clear
that if you were going
to be a professional
geographer, one could not take
such maps as this seriously.
What one had to focus on was
a scientific map, in England,
the ordinate survey one
inch to one-mile map.
Here in the United States, it
would be the USGS topographic quad
which may be familiar to you.
Of course, the younger members
of the audience know nothing
about such paper maps, because they
find all their cartography off the
internet, particularly Google Maps.
But in the old days, when
we looked at paper maps,
it would be the USGS quads here
and the ordinate survey
topo maps in the UK.
And it was not until
much later in my career,
when I was involved co-editing and
contributing to the historical atlas
of Maine, which has been mentioned,
that I began to think again
about the use of pictorial
imagery in cartography.
The atlas is in many ways, a
standard cartographic production,
presenting information
in a very objective way,
which can get a bit tedious, map
after map of sort of bar graphs
and pie charts and so forth,
and proportional circles.
And so, I try to leaven
the graphic imagery
by bringing in pictorial elements.
On one of the maps that we did
this was on Portland, Maine --
the land use of Portland, Maine.
I'm not going to get into the sort
of triangle that you can see here,
but just draw your attention
to the images of buildings
around the central graphic.
These were from a map published
I think in the 1840s or 1850.
And we had them digitally removed
and scattered around on this map
to try and give a sort of
three-dimensional sense
to the Portland landscape.
And then almost, one of the last
maps I was working on for the atlas,
was tourism and thought
about tourist maps.
And these are often pictorial.
And so, we've got two examples here.
One on the right is a gas
map from I think the 1940s.
The one on the left is an artistic
map that was produced a series
of state maps, in fact
for the country.
And it was while bringing
these maps --
researching these maps and
putting them in the atlas,
that got me interested
in graphic presentation,
and the way different types
of information are presented.
USGS and ordinate survey maps
do certain things very well,
but other things they don't do.
And pictorial maps are excellent
at presenting perhaps softer,
more cultural features, such as
landscape, history, memory, emotion.
Many pictorial maps are great fun.
They have humor in them.
They show pride of place or pride
of state or pride of region,
and they also show that rather
nebulous sense of place,
which is often talked about,
particularly in literature and art.
And it's that cultural sense
of particular places and states
and regions that I think
pictorial maps present so well.
And these kind of cultural elements,
just were not being captured
in the USGS topo maps.
So, I began to think about this
and particularly having worked
so closely on this atlas
for more than a decade,
about how we convey information,
pictorial graphic information,
to the reader.
And once the atlas was finished,
I was somewhat intellectually
exhausted and thought,
"I really need to do something fun."
And it seemed that pictorial maps
was an obvious outlet and a sort
of recreational project almost.
And when I started to look into
it, I realized that you know,
scholars had looked at it.
It had simply not been
treated seriously at all.
There were maybe one article I
think, or one of two articles
about the genre of pictorial maps.
So, I thought, this is excellent.
There's a big gap here
in the literature
and our cartographic knowledge.
I'm going to explore the topic.
And that led me of course here
to the Library of Congress.
Now, pictorial images are
maps, and not a phenomenon
of 20th Century American.
They go right back to Medieval Map
of Mundi and through the Great Age
of Dutch Cartography as shown here.
This map by Lynn Showton
[phonetic], and you can see galleons
and various beasts
I think in Africa,
and the very elaborate
toniquolin [phonetic] and cartouche
with the inset of the islands below.
So, not a new phenomenon, but the
pictorial elements start to drop
out through the 18th Century
with the enlightenment
and a push towards a more
scientific type of cartography.
There is a revival, particularly
here in the United States,
in the late 19th Century
and early 20th century,
with the rise of bird's eye views.
And the United States was
really a great producer
of bird's eye views
of towns and cities.
And here we have a map from
the early the early 1920s,
which is a bird's eye view of Fresno
County amid California's Garden
of the Sun, which is
called a pictorial map.
And I think you can start to see
a bit of a shift from that sort
of classic, bird's eye, into a
more consciously pictorial map.
And you can see around the
borders, these various photographs
and artistic renderings of
the Sierras and Yosemite.
Perhaps the greatest influence
on the genre, actually comes
from the UK, and it's the map on the
left, again done by MacDonald Gill.
It's the Wonderground map of London.
It was produced in 1914
for the London Underground.
Frank Pick, a very
innovative general manager
of the London Underground,
wanted to publicize the system,
and hired various artists
to produce maps
and among them was MacDonald Gill,
who produced this spectacular map
that was put up in
Underground railway stations,
and then was produced for retail
to the general public,
it was so popular.
So, this is 1914, the beginnings
of the First World War,
at least in Europe.
And it must have come across to the
United States in the late teens,
early twenties, because
the map on the right is
by two American commercial
artists, Olsen and Blake,
who were based in Boston.
And this is a map of Boston,
published by Houghton Mifflin,
again a Boston publishing
firm, a very famous firm.
And it shows Boston.
And I think by pairing them, you can
see that really the direct influence
from MacDonald Gill, across the
Atlantic to this map of Boston
and the way the map is created,
I think the yellow roads
is a dead giveaway.
Blake and Olsen denied,
or said they had not,
looked at other artistic maps,
but I think they must have
known MacDonald Gill maps.
And certainly, Gill's map is being
retailed over here by the 1930s.
I found advertisements
for Gill's map.
But I suspect copies were
circulating here earlier.
So, that is an influence.
Bird's eye views are an influence.
And then 1925 is the
Great Exposition in Paris
that becomes known as art deco.
And art deco comes across the
Atlantic, to the United States,
and really influences everything
from jewelry to skyscrapers.
Think of the great
Manhattan skyscrapers,
many of them art deco
pieces of architecture.
And it comes into the graphic arts.
This is just a publicity folder for
Reno, trying to intercept tourists
on the way to San Francisco,
and the Pageant
of the Pacific Exhibition
there on Treasure Island.
And it has the various art
deco motifs which I'm sure many
of you are familiar with.
The United States in the 20s, we
think of it as the Roaring 20s.
The country is booming.
Companies have -- are
flush with income.
They have large advertising budgets.
They can hire innovative commercial
artists to sell products as,
I think you can see in
this illustration here.
And so, everything is
really set for an explosion
of genre of pictorial maps.
A great interest in
graphics and advertising.
And from really 1926, we start
to see just a massive
outpouring of pictorial maps.
There's one or two,
1925, a bit earlier,
but really 1926 is the key year,
just after that Paris exhibition,
and a number of the exhibits
from Paris were brought over
and exhibited in major museums
here in the United States.
So, avant-garde commercial artists,
could go to, say, the Boston Museum
of Fine Arts, and see the
latest work coming out of Paris,
and could use it for their
own work here in the states.
This is really a genre
pushed by commercial artists.
We're not dealing with the Great
American Artist at the 20s and 30s.
I think Rockwell Kent did a
few commissions of estates
in a pictorial map genre,
but almost overwhelmingly,
these maps were produced by
commercial artists such as here,
George Annand in his
studio, in his apartment,
in Manhattan, in the 1930s.
He's just actually got a
commission and he's smoking a cigar.
I had the great pleasure of meeting
his daughter who's now in her 80s.
She lives in Brookline,
Mass., and she could tell me
about this picture and
the context for it.
In fact, supplied me
with the photograph.
And I love it because he's at
his drafting desk and he was a --
perhaps a very typical commercial
artist who did pictorial maps.
He did commissions of -- for wealthy
New Yorkers, of their estates there
on Long Island and in Connecticut.
But he was also working
with major companies
like Nabisco to advertise products.
And I think that's a more general
point, is that many of the artists
who produced pictorial maps,
are turning their hands
to many types of product.
Book jackets, book
illustrations, etcetera, etcetera.
In fact, George Annand may well have
produced the first pictorial map
as a book jacket.
This is the period where we're
shifting from embossed book --
book covers, to the
paper wraparound jacket.
And so, that's gives
opportunity to people like Annand
to produce colorful book jackets.
Th major American map publishers
gets involved in pushing these maps
and commissioning maps, selling
maps, and hear is Hagstrom's catalog
of what they call Decorative
and Historical Maps.
But you can see, two pictorial
maps are framed in this room.
This is basically showing how
you can use pictorial maps
to decorate your house.
So, by the late 20s, 30s, into
the 50s, the major map producers,
map publishers in the United
States, are behind the genre.
I should say that the United
States is really the leader
in pictorial map production,
although I've mentioned
MacDonald Gill.
He was almost a lone artist in the
UK, producing this type of map.
Produced superb maps, but
really, he's one of a kind.
And it's here in the United States
that we see the explosion
of the genre.
And perhaps that's not surprising
given the prosperity of the US
in the 20s, and even the 30s
and then post-Second World War.
And the great attention
to advertising.
And of course, the importance
of American popular culture.
These maps are a form of
American popular culture.
And I think because of that, they're
not being treated very seriously
until perhaps I got going with them.
Maybe they still won't be
treated seriously, who knows?
I've not had any scullery
reviews of the book yet,
but they haven't been
treated seriously.
And I think that perhaps reflects
their embodiment of an aspect
of American popular culture, but
as I think, we all are aware,
American popular culture just takes
over much of the western world.
From the 20s onwards,
think of Hollywood
and as we shall see, Disney.
And it is still very dominant today.
So, I think no surprise to find
this genre so well developed here
in the U.S. Now, I've mentioned that
these maps were not taken seriously
by the academics and scholars.
I certainly never came across
some in my geographical training.
And it's really thanks to these two
women about whom I know very little.
Ethel Fair on the left.
Muriel Parry on the right.
And these two ladies, both
librarians, collected maps -
these pictorial maps - when they
were really I think, unfashionable.
Ethel Fair, remarkably was
collecting back in the 30s.
She actually has an article in
the Wilson Journal for Librarians
from the 1930s, about
her collection.
So, even then, it was recognized
that she put together an
extraordinary collection
of these maps.
Muriel Parry is more
Second World War, post-war.
You see her here in the map library
of the American Geographical Society
when it was headquartered at that
time in the 1940s, in Manhattan.
And then she later
worked as a map librarian
in the State Department
here in Washington.
And these two women, for
whatever reason, become interested
in the genre, they collect
them, and then they donate them
to the Library of Congress.
And it was Ralph Ehrenberg who told
me about these two collections.
I think in total, about 2,000 maps.
And in a mad three days, I
went through those 2,000 maps,
looking at what they'd collected.
And they really have, not only
a representative collection,
but many of the great
stars of the genre.
And most of the maps are
in immaculate condition
because they were buying them
as they were being published.
For those of us, like myself,
who try to pick up some
of these maps today, they're
often in a rather battered state.
So, the collections we've
got down in the Geography
and Map Division here in the Madison
Building, in outstanding quality.
So, these two collections
formed the basis of the book,
at least 90% I think of
the maps in the book,
are based on the Fair
and Parry collections.
As you well know, the Library of
Congress is a copywrite library,
however many of these maps,
because they were ephemera
essentially, were not copywrited.
And so, the Library of Congress does
not have a comprehensive collection
of pictorial maps.
Certainly, the Fair and Parry
collections are outstanding.
But the Library of Congress,
unlike perhaps books,
does not have everything
that was published.
And so, I looked elsewhere,
the American Geographical
Society Library in Milwaukee,
the Los Angeles Public Library,
the Boston Public Library,
the Newberry Library in Chicago,
and found a few maps that,
and don't appear to be in the
LOC collection, but as I say,
the foundation of the
research was here
in the Geography and Map Collection.
And I'm most grateful that
these two women put these
collections together.
Another point to make here is that
women play a very important role
as creators, as graphic
designers in this genre.
And I'll mention one or two
women as I go through examples.
And that's perhaps not surprising,
given we're talking about the 20s,
30s, 40s, even into the 50s, where a
traditional employment for women was
as teachers and as librarians.
And so, they would be interested
in communication and educating,
particularly to children.
And so, naturally I think, they
found the pictorial map format
of great interest and become
creators of pictorial maps.
Well, as I say, there were 2,000
maps in the two collections
and many more maps
I found elsewhere.
And so, the challenge was to
create some kind of order.
So, I essentially created five
categories which I'm going to go
through rapidly, to give you a sense
of the breadth and the creativity
and the vitality of the
pictorial map genre.
I've mentioned Disney
and Disney, Walt Disney,
gets into the genre very early
with this Mickey Mouse map
of the United States that was
produced as a map that was folded
up in a pencil case, that was
distributed to school children
across the United States.
So, you can imagine the
millions of boxes of pencils
with this map rolled up and what
an extraordinary way to get Mickey
and Goofy and Donald
into children's minds.
They didn't even need
to see the cartoons.
They could just see
it on a pictorial map.
And this is just the beginnings
of Disney's involvement.
So, this is what I
call "Maps to Amuse."
So, this is one example.
The Lindgren Family of
Spokane, Washington State,
during The Depression, decided to
create smiles on people's faces
and also perhaps make a bit of
money, by creating pictorial maps
of western national parks.
They were very successful.
There's an example here of
Yellowstone and Jackson Hole,
and after the end of
the Second World War,
they got into the decal
market and produced --
I think they became the leading
decal manufacturer and producer.
And so, we've got a decal
on the right showing
the simplification
of the map on the left.
And so, if you were a tourist to
one of those great national parks,
you could pick up a decal and
put it in your car window.
And that of course was very
popular for many decades,
and perhaps collect
these decals as well.
And then, the phenomenon
of the brag map.
You've perhaps all seen that
famous New Yorker cover of the view
from Manhattan and
how the world kind
of just falls away beyond
Manhattan Island and the center
of the universe is Manhattan.
And so, showing a very
narrow view perhaps
or perspective of average
New Yorker.
Well that type of map, is not
just confined to New York City,
but is found across the country
and the usual suspects here is
the Texan view and I hardly need
to say anything about it, except
Texas, as you can see protrudes
into Canada which according
to my geographical
training is not the case.
So, we get this brag maps, being
produced to boost particular states
or cities, Los Angeles, and
Florida, New York, involved in this.
So, the various types of maps
to amuse, to create a chuckle
or put a smile on someone's face.
Then there's a second category which
are maps with a didactic function.
Maps to educate.
And here is a publicity blurb
for picture history maps
from the Graphic History
Association based in New York.
And notice, designed by
Elizabeth Shirtcliff [phonetic].
She produced several
wonderful pictorial maps,
but I found almost nothing
about Elizabeth Shirtcliff.
I wish perhaps the family
might still have an archive.
One of the challenges of
this work was not only --
it was one thing to find the maps.
The second thing was to find
the archives about the artists.
I had some strokes of good fortune,
but then there are other artists
such as Shirtcliff, I could
find very little about.
But she was interested
in producing maps
to educate particularly children.
And so, we get this kind
of map being produced.
This is by actually an English
ex-patriot, Ernest Clegg,
who came to the United States after
the end of the First World War.
He was a military officer.
And his maps are distinguished
by a very fine calligraphy.
And this is a map produced
or published
by Washington's National Cathedral
in honor of an anniversary
of George Washington, and it's --
if you look at, a very
splendidly designed map.
But clearly, this is
not a map to amuse.
This is a map to educate
about George Washington.
And there are a number of maps of
American presidents and great men
and women as well,
that are produced.
A map produced by another
woman, Emma Bourne, in 1940.
America: A Nation of One
People from Many Countries,
published by the Council
Against Intolerance in America.
This map, I am fortunate to have
a copy of this map, and it was put
on an exhibit at the Osher
Map Library at the University
of Southern Maine, in Portland.
And I was told by the
curator that this was one
of the most popular maps in the
exhibition because of course,
it resonates so much with
our present situation.
So, a map in 1940,
campaigning against any type
of intolerance here
in the United States.
So, clearly again, a map with a
very serious, didactic purpose.
And a third example, is I think one
of the great literary maps produced.
This was produced by
Edward Everett-Henry
for a printing company
in Cleveland, Ohio.
This is a map that has had a
certain amount of publicity
through the Library of
Congress's exhibition
and book a few years
ago, about literary maps.
So, this is reasonably well-known,
and of course it's showing
the voyage of the Pequod
in Hermann Melville's "Moby Dick,"
and I just love the way
Everett-Henry merges the sort
of two dimensions of the map form.
So, we have the outline of the
South Atlantic and Indian Ocean
into the Pacific, as
well as the sort
of more three-dimensional imagery of
the voyage and the people involved.
So, a very powerful map and there's
a number of these that he produced
in the late 1950s, early 1960s.
Then there are maps,
a third category
of places and regions and states.
And indeed, of countries as well.
And this is by a Cleveland
artist, Arthur Suki [phonetic],
of Miami and Miami Beach.
Clearly, it's all about
sun, down there.
This was a map produced as a
publicity piece by the Miami Herald.
It's I think quite rare
to find and this copy is
from the Library of Congress.
And you get that art deco sense
of the radiant sun that he's put
in the bottom right
corner, illuminating
and warming up the scene.
This is a map I particularly enjoy.
And then out on the west coast,
a map by Michael Baltekal Goodman
who was at Berkeley and
this is again, a 1930's map,
showing Berkeley and Oakland
and San Francisco Bay,
and I think you can see the
various art deco tropes.
The sort of chevron
waves, the electric winds.
We often have the winds
from the four quarters shown
on Medieval maps, often
get replicated
on pictorial maps of
the 20th Century.
And you can see in the top left
that a rather electric wind there,
with the sort of zig zags.
And then there's a leaping antelope
among the vegetation back here,
which is straight out
of French art deco.
So, a wonderfully art deco piece.
This was actually on my first
day, looking at the Fair
and Parry collections, I had looked
at oh, probably 7 or 800 maps.
I was exhausted.
It was getting towards closing time
at 5 o'clock, and the last folder
for the day was brought out.
And the very last map, was this one.
And I thought, "My goodness.
This is the highlight of the day.
The best has been saved for last."
There's a large piece,
very colorful.
Makes a tremendous impact to see it.
And I urge you to see these
as objects in themselves,
rather than digital imagery on
the web or in this presentation,
because there is a certain
physicality and visceral reaction
to them when you see
them as objects.
And then this one by Vernon
Farrow, a glorious bird's eye view
of Manhattan, 1926,
capturing the roaring 20s.
And finally, in terms of pride of
place, a number of universities,
Harvard, Cornell, and
in this case Chicago,
produced maps for their alums,
celebrating their campuses.
So, this is the University
of Chicago campus --
a particularly colorful campus map.
Then industry got into the act,
so another category is maps
for industry, and industry wants to
advertise its services and products.
So, here we have the Alaska Shipping
Company selling its passenger
sailings up to Alaska from Seattle.
Notice the cartoon
strip at the bottom.
Again, a very cartoony map
done by Joe Schull [phonetic],
a western artist for
Great Northern Railway,
advertising the Great Northern
service to Glacier National Park.
I love the bears confronting
the tourists
in the [inaudible] back there.
The airlines got involved
in the act.
So, this is Pan-Am, the
great international airline,
advertising its first
routes to Latin America.
And again, we've got
humor here with the birds
on the equatorial line there.
And there's lots of humor
in this particular piece
by Thompson [phonetic].
And then a final map for
industry is very much industrial.
This is a map done to
celebrate the opening
of the Cleveland Terminal
Building in 1929.
Some of you may know
it, if you're from Ohio.
And essentially, the story is,
"We've created this skyscraper,"
I believe at the time the
tallest outside of New York.
"Come and do your business
in Cleveland.
We are the center of
the industrial Midwest."
And area we hear a lot about
today, the so-called Rust Belt.
But here, it's in all its glory
with the steam locomotives,
electric trains, the automobiles,
the Great Lakes freighters,
all focusing in on Cleveland.
So, it's a wonderful sort of
advertisement for this new,
office complex in downtown
Cleveland.
Then we come to the
Second World War.
So, this is my fourth category,
and we have maps for war.
This is actually before
Pearl Harbor.
The United States feels secure
behind its airplanes and battleships
and so forth, but I want
to draw your attention
to this very standard
Mercator map here that is used.
But we're at the -- on the
verge of the so-called Air Age,
which is going to change
cartography.
As you can see here, classic
Air Age map, as if we're looking
from outer space, or at
least from an airplane,
looking down on the globe.
This is a map by Howard
Burke [phonetic],
I think for the San
Francisco Examiner.
He also did work for the
Los Angeles newspapers.
And you got a very different sense
of how the world is
shown cartographically.
We moved away from the
Mercator projection,
and we've got these
pictorial elements in it.
And then I think the sort of the
grand finale are the maps produced
by the federal government,
the U.S. Navy in particular,
the Bureau of Naval Personnel.
When I was here, I was down in the
Navy yard, difficult to get into,
but to try and look at the archival
papers behind the production
of these maps.
And I think you can see that it's
really an extraordinary image.
And there was six of
these produced for the --
covering the American
war effort, globally.
And this really powerful image
of, coming across the Atlantic
and engaging with Nazi
Germany and many types
of pictorial element here.
And I think you can see sort
of Madison Avenue advertising behind
this almost sort of cinematic image.
And we know that George Annand was
working for the federal government
as other commercial artists, to
produce this kind of imagery as part
of the propaganda effort
by the United States.
So, a splendid wartime image.
And then my final category -- oh,
I'd like just to contrast this
to MacDonald Gill's map,
celebrating the Atlantic Charter,
the signing of the Atlantic Charter,
between Roosevelt and Churchill.
And this map gets published in 1944,
the same date as the previous map.
And I think you can see
that Gill is still working
with Mercator projection, really
a 19th Century image of empire --
British Empire of sea lanes
and shipping and so forth.
And the U.S. has moved into the Air
Age here with a very different way,
a very slick way of
presenting the world.
The final category of the maps
for the post-war period is
[inaudible] a catch-all.
Essentially, the genre's running
out of steam by the 1960s,
although there is still wonderful
pictorial maps being produced
to the present.
But this is the last flourish,
and here is an example
of an Air Age map using the polar
projection now which used again
by another woman, Sally DeLong
[phonetic] for a western airline.
Again, I think this is 1944, and
you can see these strange beasts
on the map that hark
back to Medieval maps.
Oil is of course essential to the
booming American economy of the 50s
and 60s, and so here General
Drafting is producing a map,
a pictorial map, of oil in America.
Just a -- probably a
freebie fold-out map,
you could get at gas stations.
The tourist agencies in various
states were getting involved.
So, here we're out in California,
pushing the Southland --
the Los Angeles area to tourists.
A map produced from
the 50s into the 60s.
Disney is thinking about Disneyland
out in Southern California,
and to get the financial backing
from the New York bankers,
he creates this pictorial
map, shown with --
to give the bankers an idea of
what it's going to look like.
So, the power of the
pictorial image.
And then, a succession of pictorial
maps are produced for Disneyland.
This is by Sam McKim
[phonetic] who was one
of his great graphic artists.
Was tremendous team of
artistic talent working not just
on the cartoons and the films,
but producing these maps.
So, Disneyland, the connection
to popular culture, I
think it's all here.
And them, Time Life is
also -- gets in on the act.
Dominant American news publisher.
And so, we've got the
launch of Sputnik
and Cold War tension being
shown in this map by R.M. Chapin
who was the Time Life staff
cartographer during the Second World
War, and then into
the 50s and early 60s.
And this is just showing the
beginnings of that Cold War tension
and the emerging space race.
And my final map, to sort
of summarize the genre,
comes out in 1969 and commemorates
the landing on the moon.
And there are many
fun elements here,
but notice the presidents
there of Kennedy, Johnson,
and Nixon, flying on the eagle.
This map was actually
produced for Merrill Lynch.
I wondered when they gave the
commission to this graphic artist,
whether they knew what
they were getting.
But it's a very humorous
take on the moon landing.
And in a sense, picks
up on that sort
of 60's counterculture at the time.
This is a bit subversive.
So, in a sense, getting back to map
as -- to amuse a mapper's humor.
By this point, the genre
is pretty well over.
And we're not getting the
output that we did in the 20s
and 30s, even in the 40s.
But still to this day, there are
graphic artists producing pictorial
maps and -- of cities.
I was just down in Charleston, South
Carolina last week and produced --
found a wonderful pictorial
map produced
by a not local architectural
firm of the Historic District.
So, it must have been hours
of work to put it together.
So, there are still very creative
people producing this kind of map
for the general public, and
seems to be still alive and well.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Very happy to take some questions.
Yes?
>> You mentioned that most of the
pictorial maps were not copywrited,
and I was curious if you could
tell us a little bit more about --
if you know why that
would be the case?
Given that they were
commercial [inaudible],
one might expect them
to be [inaudible].
>> Stephen Hornsby: Yes,
there was a fee involved.
And I've looked at some
of the paperwork on this,
and two copies had to be sent
to the Library of Congress,
along with a processing fee.
And I imagine that a number of these
publications were just so ephemeral
and were given out as freebies
that the artist just didn't think it
was worth paying the processing fee.
And so, they're not in the
Library of Congress collection.
I think it's -- that's the reason.
Yes?
>> Thank you for a wonderful talk.
Most of these maps seem in a
way to be unachievable today.
They represent degrees of artistry
that are not valued or [inaudible].
Are there any practitioners
now that you know
of who are doing [inaudible]?
>> Stephen Hornsby: I can't
tell you off the top of my head,
but I think there are some
very creative artists at work.
In fact, I've just reviewed a
book by a Boston based artist.
I did the review for Margot
Mundy, and he goes through step
by step, the artistic process.
And I'm sorry, I'm embarrassed
to say I can't remember the
artist's name but he talks
about all the types of
commercial work he does
for university campuses,
for business campuses,
anyone who needs some sort of
pictorial guide to where things are.
You can imagine, it could
be done here the Hill area,
the location of the
different buildings.
It would be a wonderful way of
showing Washington, and in fact,
in the 20s and 30s, there were maps,
and indeed into the 40s and 50s,
there were pictorial maps done
of D.C., of the mall area.
It was just a natural for a creative
artist to show the great landmarks.
And in fact, Olsen and Blake who did
the map of Boston, did three maps
for Houghton Mifflin and their
third map was of Washington D.C.
that a copy was presented
to the White House
and Calvin Coolidge
replied very graciously
or at least his staffer did.
And fortunately, the Houghton
Mifflin archives are in one
of the Harvard libraries.
And so, you can see all
of this correspondence.
But I think there are
still very creative people
who are producing these
maps, but not in the quantity
that we saw in the 20s and 30s.
>> Thank you.
>> Stephen Hornsby: Yes?
>> Are you going to see any on
Antiques Roadshow that are --
you know, can you think
about a collectible--
>> Stephen Hornsby: Yes.
>> -realm that you've maybe got
your own or [inaudible] for maybe?
>> Stephen Hornsby: Yes,
that's a great question.
Probably the greatest
private collection is
that of David Rumsey
[phonetic] out in San Francisco.
He's really given much of his
collection to Stanford now.
And he -- after I'd really done
this book, he started to collect,
and within the space of just a
few years, got at least 2,000 maps
which he then had scanned, are
on the David Rumsey map site
which is really a go-to
place to go, to see maps.
So, Rumsey got involved.
There are other serious collectors
and there are a few map dealers
that are specializing in the genre.
I was actually giving a
presentation on these maps
at the Miami International Map
Fair back in February of this year,
and the comment was, "No
one's really interested
in the old maps anymore.
Everybody wants the 20th
Century pictorials."
And so, the dealers are moving
into it, and cultivating a market.
And there are now collectors who
are putting together collections.
So, it is a very exciting,
vibrant area of collection.
>> Is there one out there that
you know people are looking for?
>> Stephen Hornsby: I mean the
Farrow map of Manhattan from 1926,
is now going for several
thousand dollars.
There's a map of Peiping [phonetic]
as it was then called Peking,
and I think because
of the Chinese market,
that's going for 4 or $5,000.
We're still not into the kind
of prices you'd get for a --
maybe a very fine 17th Century map.
I don't collect those type of maps,
but the prices are certainly rising,
which is reflecting the market.
I actually put together a reasonable
collection as a research collection,
because there wasn't a library.
Being up in Maine, I couldn't
get down to the Library
of Congress every week to
look at the collections.
So, I purchased some maps for my own
research and I'm glad I did it four
or five years ago, and not now.
So, yes, it is a growing
area of collection.
Yes?
>> And what criteria do you
use to distinguish between--
>> Stephen Hornsby: Great.
>> -art and just placemats
that we see [inaudible].
>> Stephen Hornsby: Great question.
Yes, yes. I resisted
putting a placemat in,
but maybe I should have done.
What I wanted to do with the
book, was to give the, in a sense,
the greatest highlights, as well
as a representation of the variety
and diversity of the genre.
So, there are maps in the book
that are relatively easy to find.
Maps produced by the oil companies,
for example, or by Disney.
These are maps that some of you may
well have kicking around at home.
So, they've got very
little intrinsic value
but they are producing and
showing a pictorial image
of the earth's surface.
But I also wanted to show the
maps such as the Vernon Farrow map
of Manhattan, which
are really quite rare
and are splendid examples
of artistic endeavor.
It must have taken hours
of work to have created
that three-dimensional image of
the skyscrapers of Manhattan.
So, that's what I wanted to do.
Show the -- some of the great maps
that are particularly in the Fair
and Parry collections, as well
as the everyday type of map
that you'd have in
your car or back home.
So, that was the kind of criteria.
A lot of it of course, I was
dealing with 2,000 maps in the Fair
and Parry, and clearly,
I had to make a selection
and that inevitably comes
down to one's eye and interest
and what you learn about
these maps over time.
And you appreciate them
the more research you do.
You start to realize,
"Oh, this is a key map."
So, for example, the map
of Boston I showed you
that Houghton Mifflin produced,
that's about as early --
I mean there was one of New York
in 1925, but the one of Boston,
published by Houghton Mifflin,
is really almost the first map.
So, that has to kind of go in.
And you've got to talk about
the Houghton Mifflin maps
and there's a number
of them in the book.
And then other publishers as well.
So, there are things you've
got to sort of sort out
and make part of the narrative.
>> So, you really feel that
that copied Gill and so that--
>> Stephen Hornsby: Yes.
>> -was really the beginning?
>> Stephen Hornsby: You
can see how clearly.
I mean, they're not just making
this up out of their heads.
They've looked at that
Gill Wonderground map.
But what happens is that,
although Gill might be an impetus,
there are many other influences
coming in, such as art deco.
I wouldn't say that Gill -- I mean
there are some art deco elements
in later Gill maps, but I
mean, it just takes off here
in the United States and
creates its own momentum.
And they don't need -- these
commercial artists don't need
to look to the U.K.
or to a French artist.
It becomes an American genre.
And this is something I
argue strongly in the book,
that this is a phenomenon
of American popular culture.
And the greatest achievements
I think,
are done here in the United States.
Yes?
>> Have you done any similar
research in the Asian pictorial maps
or any comparison of them?
>> Stephen Hornsby: Yes,
that's a great question.
And there are certainly maps
coming up out of Japan for example.
I am not an Asian specialist.
So, and I wanted to keep this
restricted to the United States.
But there certainly are
a woodblock maps coming
out of Japan that I'm aware of.
And particularly associated with
the 1930s and the Second World War.
Interestingly, Muriel
Parry as I mentioned,
was a librarian at
the State Department.
And she was posted
overseas, in fact, to Japan,
after the end of the
Second World War.
And what distinguishes
her collection
from Ethel Fair's collection --
Ethel Fair's collection
is primarily,
almost entirely American maps,
is that Muriel Parry collected
across the globe, so there's
maps from every continent,
perhaps except Antarctica.
But maps from Africa,
Australasia, South Asia, etcetera,
Latin America, South America.
And so, I got a sense looking at her
maps, probably about 900 of them,
of what other countries
were producing.
And I think if there was sort of a
great group of maps, say from Japan
or China, she would probably
have got her hands on them.
And I think there are some
Japanese maps in the collection.
And so, it was the sort
of the looking at her --
the diversity of her collection
that I began to realize
that in fact the United States
was a leader in this genre.
Okay. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at Loc.gov.